alex rodriguez and lindsay shookus were
spotted together
at a party in the hamptons over the
weekend this is another level
yeah you know lindsay shookus who dated
ben affleck yes
the ben affleck who recently rekindled
his romance with his ex-fiance jennifer
lopez
who was going to marry erod but called
it quits in april and now
jlo's x is just casually hanging out
with ben's ex i don't know how that
happened
but calm down alex and lindsey are just
friends
a source tells et that the former
baseball player and saturday night live
producer have known each other for 15
years
and even though the pair were seen
sitting side by side celebrating her
birthday
the source adds the two are not involved
romantically and a-rod was at the party
for only an hour
the source notes he's friends with a lot
of women and isn't going to be dating
for a while
a lot happened just last week another
source told e.t alex is officially
moving on from jennifer
she's really funny and amazing and
she's just magical she you know while
the former mlb star initially held out
hope that he and the 51 year old singer
could reconcile
he's now accepting that it's just not in
the cards
well when jennifer and alex first split
he wanted to work things out and still
held on to hope that he and jayla would
get back together
but he's come to terms with the fact
that it's over now it's because it's
really hard
back in april the two announced in a
joint statement that they were calling
off their engagement
of course jen has since moved on with
ben affleck the pair was previously
engaged from 2002 to 2004.
the source says that alex is very aware
of the attention surrounding jen and ben
but he's trying to focus on himself and
his future instead
we really have a special connection that
way so
yeah he was he was amazing meanwhile
lindsay and ben were on and off from
2017 to 2019.
a source told et at the time that their
breakup was due to their busy schedules
and they still had a lot of love for
each other
you